[Music]
hello I'm Ashley Vance and here we are
for another episode of hello world from
home we have acquired toilet paper
thanks to my wife's valiant efforts
which is good and what's even better is
today we are going to talk to Jonathan
Rothberg a very famous scientist
especially in the gene sequencing world
he happens to be quarantined in Florida
on his yacht which is called the gene
machine and has a laboratory on it and
and as this virus started to hit and
move across the world
Jonathan swung his businesses to attack
it in a few different ways and so let's
go check in with Jonathan and see what
he's been up to you so you have five
five kids on the boat or I have five
children all on the boat
these are no an Alana can I ask you guys
a question what's up I mean what's what
is life like got a boat during a
situation like this a little
claustrophobic yeah we are absolutely
not allowed to leave the boat yeah we
can't go on the dock they can do water
sports and again the only can I ask you
[ __ ] awake surfing I mean so your
boat this yacht is called the the gene
machine and obviously I could see behind
you I mean yeah it's there's all this
lab equipment tell me the story behind
this this boat and why you're on it
right now well I'm married to a
physician I was on the boat on vacation
with the kids first week of March and my
wife was on vacation all for 48 hours
till she got a note from the hospital
all hands on deck so she flew back and I
looked at the lab and said wait a minute
I spent the last twenty years making
machines to analyze massive amounts of
DNA I started one of the early genomics
companies now I need to just tell people
whether they have the virus that causes
kovat 19
or they don't have it from what I've
read you know a couple stories about
this I mean you kind of challenged your
team to to make the easiest you know
cheapest quickest test for this possible
and make it something that people could
do at their home you don't have to have
a physician that's kind of the goal that
you're after
so what the team has done and they've
been successful at the bench in our
laboratories back in Connecticut is make
a test that you can swab your throat or
put something up your nose or spit into
a tube and they can determine whether
someone has kovat 19 or not I spit in a
test tube and then I am instantly
getting an answer back on my my
smartphone and this is all happening at
home yes it's all happening at home so
how close do you feel like you guys are
now - you know me or during one of these
and getting it in my living room here
there's a few steps over the next couple
weeks we want to validate it that it
works in parallel we've brought in
people with great manufacturing scale-up
so we can make first thousands of these
kits then millions of these kits there
are 300 million people just in the
United States and they're not going to
be tested once and done if you test and
you have the virus you're going to want
to test again that you don't have it so
we're focusing on something that's
simple fast scalable you actually have
it's like a smorgasbord of inventions
that are sort of useful here you have a
company called butterfly Network and and
you guys make you know I think I think
everybody's familiar with going to get
an ultrasound if you're having a kid
especially and and you go in the
doctor's office and they bring out their
machine but essentially you've tried to
make much more accessible version of an
ultrasound yeah I said why don't we put
an ultrasound machine on a chip and got
some smart people together and this is a
chip that has that entire cart that you
see $100,000 car
put onto a chip and once something's in
a chip you know you can put it in a
device like this in this particular case
this machine has a lot of uses right I
mean obviously people are their lungs
are getting taken over by this virus and
we want to see what what condition
people are in when kovat 19 struck the
world luckily we had already sold over
15,000 of these devices physicians
immediately started to use it for
looking at the lung of these patients
now the interesting thing is there is
always a gold standard so the gold
standard is a cat scan but a cat scan
it's a couple hundred thousand dollars
and it's a limited resource so all of a
sudden now physicians are using the
butterfly IQ to triage people for I
guess what you could call this covert
lung last couple summers Justin and Noah
intern to butterfly so they're experts
at teleradiology and ultrasound they do
a demo and they are scan on each other
is it easy if it's not a they can do it
and the interesting thing is well
they'll be scanning there will be a guy
in New York who's actually guiding them
with arrows on their screen showing them
how to do it you got these two shadows
those are ribs and in between that's
lung in an injured lung you would see
what's called a lines which are vertical
striations and again this is a tool
that's being used by physicians around
the world across the United States to
help manage patients who are ill with
coronavirus how long is it until my my
you know my wife or myself yeah I can do
like a little physical and see if I've
got any nasty tumors growing or huh all
right for real the answer has changed if
you had asked me that a month
to go or two months ago I would say it's
three years out but literally in the
last two weeks all the guidelines on
Telugu ins teleradiology have changed we
just got approval at butterfly to do
remote guidance and I would say when
this is over telemedicine is going to be
dominant force kovat has changed the way
we're going to work with doctors what do
you make of the way this was handled in
the United States you know from the sort
of CDC level I mean the the testing that
went on I mean I don't know does this
make you optimistic in some sense
because now we have science going at
this really hard and all these people
over the world coming up with innovative
things or does it make you kind of
depressed you know that it seems like
our governments and our systems weren't
really prepared to handle something like
this I'm an optimist I have seven
companies and as I'm speaking to you you
know five of them are directly impacting
this we've focused on it I've seen the
rest of the world focus on it and on the
guilt side I would say the one of the
things I did a few weeks ago was
apologize to my children for myself for
our own actions I can't blame anybody
else in the sense that you would have
you would have got a maybe pursued some
of these things earlier I've known for
decades that viruses from the
environment from other animals are an
existential threat I blame myself as
much as anybody else I promised myself
on the end of February this would be the
last pandemic where we didn't have a
diagnostic kit by everybody's toothbrush
and I think many people like myself
instead of blaming other people are
acting keeping the receipt and doing
everything we can
you
you